The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I'm Sanjoy Mahajan.
This course is Teaching
College-Level Science and
Engineering.
The course is intended for
graduate students some towards
the end of their PhD who are
intending to go onto academic
teaching careers.
But all graduate students
are welcome, and even
undergraduates who have a strong
interest in teaching.
The goal of the course is to
give some preparation and
background into the principles
of teaching, so graduate
students and in fact as
undergraduates too, all get
the same for their specific
research area.
For example, in physics, they'll
learn the principles
of conservation of momentum
and energy.
But in teaching, everyone is
basically just thrown to the
wolves and figured, well, if you
know your subject, you can
teach or given very little
preparation.
So the idea is to actually
show that teaching and
thinking about teaching
is a very serious
intellectual activity.
And there's general ideas and
principles that can be used to
make teaching much
more successful.
And therefore, students learn
much more and enjoy what
they're learning.
Many departments encourage their
students who they know
are going on to teaching
careers.
They say, well, you might
actually find this course
interesting.
It's paired also with another
new program at MIT, called the
TA certificate program, which
is a non-credit option where
students do about six or seven
seminars of an hour and a half
each and do work for
each seminar.
Here, this is the sort
of four-credit
cousin of that course.
And it's for students who want
to do everything in one
semester and want something on
their transcript as well.
So at the end of each lecture,
I give out a short sheet that
has three questions on it.
One is what was most confusing
today or what do you wonder
about most?
What example or teaching
technique
worked well or not well?
And any other comments?
And so at the end of each
session, the students have one
or two minutes to
fill that out.
And at the end of the
next session, I
answer all the questions.
I was just amazed at the
thoughtfulness of the
questions and how right on they
were and how many useful
suggestions I got for when I
teach the class the next time.
Many students have told me
they think everyone who
teaches should take it.
And some told me also that
they wish some of their
professors had taken those
classes, their professors from
when they were undergraduates.
But on the other hand, if it
were required, then it
wouldn't be such a lively
atmosphere as it is now, where
we have students who really are
fascinated by teaching and
are therefore much more
motivated to contribute.
But the theme that I got from
many, many students was, wow,
this has really helped them
thinking about their teaching
and said oh, finally, this may
be the only preparation I get
in teaching and I'm really
glad I had that.